at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking you know else your personal
question
no it is
I must - any organism living tissue over
metal endoskeleton this episode of the
Tim Farriss shows brought to you by
linked in the write higher can make a
huge impact on your business
the wrong hire can create your business
and I have seen example after example
from thousands of my readers at a
minimum where they've told me stories of
how finding the right person at the
right time and in some cases not even
asking what should I do but asking who
should I find because that person can
help me determine what exactly to do
more intelligently and I've had a chance
to hire two such people in the last year
and that has just made my business take
a quantum leap forward and my complexity
in my personal and business life get cut
dramatically and this type of
simplification cannot be overvalued we
think a lot about hiring and I think a
lot about hiring and it is a skill that
I've had to learn it is important to
find the right person but where do you
find that person you can post a job on a
job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
very often so don't leave finding
someone great to chance when you can
post your job exactly where people go
every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job boards but 9 out of
10 members are open to new opportunities
and with 70% of the US workforce
on LinkedIn posting there is the best
way to get your job opportunity in front
of more of the right people and you can
be very very highly targeted and
specific people who are qualified for
the role you have and ready for
something new this is where you find
them it's the best way to find that
person that key person who will help you
grow your business and this is why a new
hire is made every 10 seconds using
LinkedIn that's bonkers every 10 seconds
so head to linkedin.com forward slash
Tim and get $50 off your first job post
that's a linkedin.com forward slash Tim
T I am to get $50 off your first job
post linkedin.com forward slash Tim take
a look
terms and conditions do apply well hello
boys and girls this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show I am recording out in
nature because we should all get out in
nature more often and my guest this
episode is Doug McMillon president and
CEO of Walmart that is a big company and
a lot of people in Silicon Valley and
elsewhere talked about Walmart as a big
company but they don't really look into
the details and I'm gonna give you some
facts and figures that will blow your
mind in a moment but how did this come
to be well I want to thank Doug and his
entire team for helping to make it
happen I visited the Heartland summit in
Bentonville Arkansas and I would
recommend checking it out the Heartland
summit org which is about of course
making us think about more than just the
coasts and we are strongest when we're
most connected to each other and the
gaps that we experienced in the u.s.
inequality and disconnection related to
education health income skill gaps and
so on will not be solved just by
California in New York so it was a real
fantastic experience to spend time in
Bentonville with people from all across
the u.s. at the Crystal Bridges Museum
of American Art which was the venue and
this is absolutely mind-blowing
jaw-dropping as a location I encourage
everybody to check it out Crystal
Bridges org and let's jump into Walmart
first and Doug second so Walmart here's
some stats in fiscal year 2018 Walmart
registered approximately five hundred
billion in revenue which is five billion
more than Belgium's GDP and there are
many other countries of course I think
Austria among them that aren't dwarfed
by Walmart if Walmart were a country it
would be the 25th largest economy in the
world
Walmart serves 265 million customers
week in 20
seven countries and across more than
11,000 stores and of course online is
growing rapidly from an e-commerce
standpoint they have to point to roughly
million associates
that's employees worldwide which means
if Walmart were an army it would have
the second largest army in the world
behind China just to give you an idea so
greater than San Francisco and Denver
and other cities combined and close to
the population of Houston seventy-five
percent of their store management team
started as hourly associates like
stalkers cashiers cart pushers and those
managers make an average of 170k per
year Walmart Falls thousands of patents
a year in categories ranging from last
mile delivery to biometrics an augmented
reality we talk about some of the
technology they have scaled grocery
pickup that is you order on a mobile
device and get groceries loaded into
your car from nothing four years ago to
more than 2,000 locations today and will
serve 70% of the population by the end
of the year how is that possible well
ninety percent of Americans live within
10 miles of a Walmart and they will
offer grocery delivery for 40% of the US
population by year-end it's really wild
how big and the scope of which the
breadth of which this company operates
and last fact Sam Walton started Walmart
with one small five-and-ten store in
rural Bentonville Arkansas in the 50s
and grew the company to be fortune
number one we hear about fortune 100
companies fortune number one and I spent
time in that initial store that very
first original store which is amazing
and I'm gonna put some photographs up of
some of the memorabilia and so on which
is quite frankly really inspiring and
I'm not getting paid to say that it's
just amazing how incredibly largest
companies become from such humble
beginnings so to Doug Doug McMillon MC
mi ll o n Facebook Doc McMillan
Instagram comm forward slash Doug
McMillon LinkedIn also Doug McMillon is
president and CEO of Walmart back in 84
Doug started out as an hourly summer
associate in Walmart distribution center
and in 1990 while pursuing his MBA he
rejoined the company as an assistant
manager
in Tulsa Oklahoma Walmart store before
moving to merchandising has a buyer
trainee and we talk a lot about his
training as a buyer very important
function within this entire organization
he worked his way up and from 2005 to
2009 he served as president and CEO of
Sam's Club owned and operated by Walmart
with sales of more than 46 billion
annually during his tenure from February
of o 9 to February of 14 Doug served as
president and CEO of Walmart
international a very fast growing
segment of Walmart's overall operations
and he has served on the board of
directors for Walmart since 2013 and is
currently the chair of the executive and
global compensation committees in
addition he serves on the board of
directors of the consumer goods forum
the us-china Business Council and
Crystal Bridges Museum of American Art
once again check out Crystal Bridges it
is incredible Crystal Bridges org back
to the bio he also serves on the
Executive Committee of the Business
Roundtable on the advisory board of the
Tsinghua University School of Economics
and management in Beijing China Doug
really came to the table he does not
normally do long interviews like this at
all and he was very willing to dance the
dance and go places that he hasn't gone
before I really enjoyed it
and plan to get back to Arkansas to
explore the very least all the mountain
biking trails you guys can do a little
Google search on that and see what pops
up but without further ado please enjoy
this very wide-ranging conversation with
Doug McMillon is that your fan group
over here
that's my plant I hired one person I'll
give him his twenty later thank you for
that so I think we should just jump
right into this what a beautiful
location it's my first time in
Bentonville and I've been absolutely
surprised by how tremendous everything
is here I booked around all last night
I've never spent any time in Arkansas so
first of all thank you for welcoming me
here and I know we have a limited set of
time to chat on stage here today so it
feels like a lot of time and I don't do
interviews that are very long and that
clock says 60 minutes on it could we at
least start it
like 15 minutes I don't want to be up
here yes off we're edging in from
different sides so I guess maybe you do
shorter usually I do 2 to 17 hours so
what we'll meet we'll meet in the middle
on this one and I thought we could just
jump right into it with a very important
question which is can you tell me about
the bait mate story and I do not know
the answer to this the bait mate story
does anyone in the room know what bait
mate is ok so when I moved into the home
office I'd worked in a store this was
1991 and I got into our buyer training
program at Walmart and I was excited
because they were putting me in Sporting
Goods I got to Sporting Goods and they
gave us fishy tackle and they the other
buyers I didn't know it immediately were
hazing me
and as the new person they said on
Saturday at the Saturday morning meeting
you must present an item that you have
negotiated a lower price on and reduced
the retail price and you have to explain
in the meeting the item the price etc
how many you can sell so I didn't know
the first thing about being a buyer it
was literally my birthday and so other
buyers helped me and we found a supplier
who makes this product called bait mate
which comes in several flavors you spray
it on a hard lure if you're fishing and
it apparently causes the fish to think
it's more real and the fish strike the
lure because it's been coded in bait
mate so it was over two dollars we
rolled it back to a dollar 97 we
maintained our margin I memorized
everything about the item and I wrote
the rest of the answers on the back of
the label and I showed up at the
Saturday morning meeting and Sam Walton
was leading the meeting and so my level
of nervous is when nervousness went from
high to somewhere off the charts so I'll
wait till the end of the line at the end
of the meeting to present bait mate to
the auditorium full of hundreds of
people with Sam Walton standing next to
me and I am shaking and my hands shaking
my voice is shaking but I get all the
information out that I'm supposed to
remember
and at the end Sam says that's all well
and good son but what makes you think
fish can smell
how did you how did you respond to that
I think I just walked away I don't
remember having anything pithy to say
but I think he was it was probably
awkward because I was so nervous and he
was trying to break the ice and but we
sold a lot of bait mate were there were
there any other particular approaches or
techniques or types of training that you
received as a buyer that that come to
mind because I don't know the first
thing certainly about buyer training but
that is would seem to be a very
important component of what Walmart does
it's certainly a big piece of it yeah
it's kind of getting that price down to
197 for an important item like they made
and what type of training did you
experience is there any particular
memories or stories that come to mind
yeah most of the learning that you have
as a merchant especially back then came
from the people around you so it's
really learning on the job and in
principles coming out like back then we
didn't really sign contracts and we had
some vendor agreements to make sure we
could pay people but your handshake was
your agreement and I remember early on
one of my supervisors a guy named Dave
Duyvil emphasizing to me we were about
to make a big commitment and the
supplier had asked for something in
writing and Dave said you need to
explain to them that your word and your
handshake is the contract and it worked
so you learned things like you're
working on behalf of a customer you
should be tough but you should be fair
you want suppliers to make money because
you want them to be here in ten years
time we're going to grow we're gonna
need supply so you know Walmart hasn't
in some circles this reputation for
being really tough oh I would say we're
tough on behalf of the customer but we
always try to be fair and if you look at
the financial results of our suppliers
they've done really well and PNG still
makes more money than Walmart does after
all this time so this has worked out
well well for everybody but we do keep
pressure on on behalf of the customer so
you learn you know kind of how to how to
think on the job but with some
principles behind you you seem to be
from what I've observed also in facebook
posts don't worry a voracious reader
and I've noticed a number of books like
team of teams by General Stanley
McChrystal that was from I think your
2006 recap where you you took a
photograph of books that have had a
she's about 16 excuse me but big impact
on your thinking that year are there any
books that you received from people that
have had a big impact on you or that you
have given out more than once to people
for any reason yeah there's that book
about Amazon that one comes to mind
everyday story yeah why why do you give
that book out you need to understand
what you're up against you know but team
of teams has been huge I'm still giving
that one out the truth is if we my house
is not far from here we went over there
right now my book my stack of books to
read is like more than me high right now
I'm behind I'm trying to catch up but
I'm I'm trying to learn and we've got to
Brett's on the front row Brett's our CFO
this morning in our officer meeting we
were talking about learning and
curiosity because retail is changing so
fast and the business we have today is
different than it was a year ago
certainly five years ago and it's going
to be different in another years time so
we are spending a lot of truant time
trying to learn new things so if you
looked at my last month and the pie
chart a time allocation you'd be
surprised how much of that time was
learning about US healthcare becoming a
digital company other things other than
how to run a brick-and-mortar retail
store because we're trying to figure out
how to get this company position to be
here in 50 years time so like on team of
teams stan mcchrystal who's who's
awesome we've spent time together he's
been to Bentonville I've been to his
place he talks about a few principles
one of them is shared consciousness and
when he was in his role in the military
he took silos that had been around for a
long time
Army Marines CIA all of those historic
silos and figured out a way to get them
to work together to get on the same page
and know the same things
once you have shared consciousness you
know what I know I know what you know
then you can pivot to empowered
execution now that you know what I know
I expect you to act without seeking
input
go and even today an officer's meeting
we were talking we've got a few hundred
officers we were talking about what our
strategy is again giving people a chance
to ask questions and then saying to
everybody
handy go this is on all of us not just
me and you now know pretty much
everything I know
so those principles that you can glean
from books and things like that really
helpful how do you pick books because I
think everyone here whether it's a stack
of books to the knee or just considering
all the books their friends might
recommend or that they might see
recommended on social media might feel a
paradox of choice stress about what to
read and you have a lot on your plate
you have a lot of responsibilities if
you think back say in the last year to
anything you've read doesn't have to be
the last year but how did you find that
book or how did you select that book as
something worthy of your time mm-hmm
I've bet some of you in the room have
the same situation I do I don't have a
shortage of books because they're
constantly being sent to me the
challenge is filtering through which one
you're going to read next so right now
I'm about a third of the way through Ray
Dalio sprin suppose and that's because
Greg Penner our Chairman asked me to
read it so it went to the top of the
stack
and I'm finding that one hard to read
but most of the ones that I've been
choosing on my own are related to change
management and specifically becoming a
digital enterprise because that the
transformation that's underway in the
world in business and certainly at
Walmart is largely a data and technology
and automation transformation leading
through that while still retaining who
you are as a company and and the DNA and
the values and the culture that one of
our officers today during the QA grab
the microphone her name's Jody and Jody
said you said it earlier but I just want
to underline it the thing that will
cause us to win is our humanity and yeah
we need to learn how to become a digital
Enterprise but we understand we're a
company made up of 2.2 million
associates and that human interaction in
the future will matter
yes automation will do things that the
humans might not want to do mundane
routine tasks at Store level or in a
warehouse or elsewhere but it's that
personal interaction that sense of
community that I think people will want
in the future and it won't be just
digital I mean that you see next door or
Facebook or others that are creating a
digital sense of community because we're
all learning that has some flaws
associated with it this sense that you
can have when you come to a place you
know we hope it's a store sometimes
where you interact with others could be
special and warm and safe and if you can
do that while delivering good prices and
all the other stuff we got to do we
think we've got an advantage I did come
across a mention of virtual reality and
training employees or associates maybe
even executives I don't know is that
currently underway or is that something
planned and could you just describe that
because I was not aware of that yes so
our our us leadership team Greg for and
Judith McKenna and others a few years
ago took an idea that they'd seen us
practice in the UK to put training
academies in our stores and now around
the United States we have about 200
locations dotted around the map
that are 138 of them actually are in the
back rooms of stores we've we've been
able to reduce our inventory and create
classrooms so they're nice classrooms
equipped with technology mobile
technology large screens really really
well done and as you're getting trained
on interesting things not just how to
execute a retail store but also some
soft skills like we're teaching people
how to have a difficult discussion using
VR so you know if you're if you are a
supervisor or a leader at Walmart you
probably weren't trained to coach
someone for improvement you you might
shy away from conflict for example so
these VR headsets have an avatar and if
you put one on right now Tim you would
have a conversation and at the end of
that conversation when you take the
headset off it would score you and tell
you how you did in that conversation
watching the other purse the avatars
facial expressions and the words that
come back so we're trying to help people
grow for the jobs we have and as
automation happens and some of them go
on to other jobs help prepare them for
more than that but we also teach people
how to do routine tasks like so you know
Ivanka Trump is interested in workforce
training and she heard about the
programs we were doing and wanted to
come to a store so I met her in Mesquite
Texas about a month ago and we put VR
goggles on her and she stocked our
vegetable wall what we call the wet wall
that's got leafy greens on it and stuff
like that she scored a 12 out of 20 so
we got a little work to do there
but you can use VR in ways that you know
get you off the sales for let you have
an opportunity to really learn when
you're not interrupted by customers and
we'll have 17,000 VR headsets deployed
by the end of the year for things like
that that's incredible I want to talk a
little bit about your personal practices
because you have of course many
responsibilities to other people but I
would imagine at some point you have to
put on your oxygen mask first before
helping others and keep yourself focused
which you clearly are in the Walmart
Museum last night which I found
endlessly fascinating I expected to find
it interesting but I really found it
fascinating I fixated on Sam Waltons
keychain next to his red pickup and who
there's a gigantic metal plate about
five times the size of say a nail file
and in huge font that says go for it I
was just imagining in my mind how he
might have referred to that at different
points making different decisions do you
have any reminders built into your life
or any quotes that you think of often
that might in some way resemble that I
think that go for it was a phrase we
used in one of our annual we had kind of
a theme for the year and we were growing
so fast and and that was really a
rallying cry at one point for me
personally the first thing that comes to
mind is a cross that I have in my office
there's a Sam's Club member that I met
years ago named Martha Hawkins and we
happen to see Martha in Montgomery
Alabama a couple of weeks ago she runs a
restaurant but she's got an incredible
personal story overcoming a drug drug
addiction and serving others and we
asked her to come to a Sam's Club
meeting and give us feedback on what we
could do better for small business
owners and restaurant owners and I we
didn't rehearse these things and I'm
standing in front of all of our club
managers with a group you know it's five
or ten times bigger than this and she
grabs the microphone and starts giving
her personal testimony it was awesome
and we've just been pen pals since then
and I've been in Montgomery a couple
times
at her place and she sent me this big
cross and these wonderful notes about
your in this big job you need support
I'm there for you I'm gonna encourage
you and I'm gonna pray for you and she
says stuff like when you show up at the
restaurant like I prayed all the
calories out of the food if that works
let me know yeah Jim peach cobbler that
didn't feel to me like that had been
accomplished but that's that there are
other mementos with that that comes to
mind now I I had read somewhere well let
me backtrack you are clearly very
curious and I think to maintain that
level of curiosity which is necessary
for the business certainly there you
need to sustain a level of humility and
the different ways to do that so a
friend of mine who's been on my podcast
Alexis Ohanian who's the co-founder of
read it at one point was told by Yahoo
exact very early on you are a rounding
error and so he put that up on the wall
for his entire team to see she ended up
working out pretty well for them I had
read and this may not be true so please
correct me not everything on the
internet turns out to be true I found
out recently that on your phone at least
at some point this was in an interview
you had the top 10 retailers I want to
say from the last five decades on your
phone can you explain why that was or
why that is yeah cuz retailers grow and
die and I've been doing this almost 30
years now which is amazing to me because
I still feel ected in some ways we're
just getting getting started but if
you're a student of retail
I suppose it's probably true for other
industries more or less but in retail
they have a good idea they have a great
founder they start moving they expand
and then something happens over time
they get complacent they have too much
success they don't manage inventory and
they go so if you go back and look at
when Walmart Kmart and Target started
which all started in 1962 Dollar General
I think did at the same year the
retailers that were before them Sears is
interesting
talk about this week they thought they
had it I mean who are these upstarts
Walmart started in Rogers Arkansas
where's Rogers Arkansas no way no one
was scared that day when the first
Walmart so you can go away the thing
that can keep one of the things that can
keep you from going away is an openness
to change and that's the point so if we
were there are some Walmart people in
here but if you were all Walmart people
and you had a leader up front and that
leader were to say the only thing that's
constant at Walmart is there's some more
people in here the truth is we have a
consistent purpose that we got from our
founder some values that we share those
are persistent too it's not just change
but the fact that that's the thing that
people underestimate us to underestimate
about Walmart right now is that it has
an ability to change they they think it
is going to be what it is right now in
some cases I'm not argue most cases they
don't understand what it is right now
because it's only been explained to them
through the media they've had no
personal interaction behind the scenes
other than that other than in the stores
are online but they certainly don't
anticipate what it's going to become and
if we can keep that kind of attitude we
got a shot at surprising people and
being here in the future when a lot of
people think we won't be so openness to
change is is a prerequisite to then
initiating change but a lot of people
don't get to that second part because
change can be really scary would you
mind talking about any particular scary
decision for you and walk us through how
you thought about it as you're going
through it and that could be this it
could be a decision it could just be a
difficult or dark moment for you because
what I'd like to do whenever I have
these types of conversations is to
humanize the person I'm talking to so
that people who are listening don't
think that and maybe this is the case
but every time you've stepped up to bat
you've hit a home run because that can
be the impression that some people come
away with otherwise so could you walk us
through a difficult time a DIF
Joyce and how you experienced that from
this week it's thinking about all the
time no less I was taking we anything
that anything that sticks out it could
be from 20 years ago 30 years ago it
doesn't doesn't matter timewise but
something that was truly truly difficult
for you well you have them I mean there
are a lot of them but I guess one of the
themes that comes to mind as
acquisitions these are not small
decisions to acquire a company big or
small
there are founders Sandee done sitting
on the front row Andy founded bonobos
he's got a baby and if he wants to put
it in the family
that's huge risk for him and I don't
want to let him down then you've got
Flipkart we invested Stuart 16 billion
dollars to buy 77% of a company that
loses a lot of money this sounds
brilliant doesn't it and before that we
we did the board and management jet calm
and gedcom was like a billion dollar run
ray and lost money and still does these
decisions we believe are necessary for a
variety of reasons which we can talk
about if you want to but once you do it
you take on those losses you take on
those people and responsibilities and
you've got to execute in a way that
makes that a really good decision and
boy we've we've read over those and
we're moving faster now we're taking
more risk but that's that's an area
where you I have a lot of a lot of
self-doubt you you have a meeting and
you hear about the strategy and you
think yeah we got to do this and then
you go home that night and you're about
to go to sleep and you think I can't do
that and then you get up the next
morning and you go back through it and
we just iterate to a point where finally
you got to make a decision and go for it
how do you navigate that because I think
a lot of people hem and haw go back and
forth on on potentially big decisions
what do you say to yourself what do you
ask yourself for who do you ask
questions to try to gain clarity
yeah well it's collective wisdom for
sure
and one of the great things it's always
been true in these jobs at Walmart
because you know people will talk to you
when you're a buyer at Walmart you can
call a CEO of a company and they'll take
your call it will take the call yes and
then the job that I'm in right now I get
exposed to incredible people and you can
use that collective wisdom by asking
questions so that's definitely part of
it but the other thing that runs through
my mind is what you know what do you
have to believe if you want to go do
this and this is the calculated bet
you're making what do you have to
believe is true yeah and if you can get
to a point where after thinking about it
you come back to the same things and
you're convicted I really do believe
those things are true then take the risk
and go for it so this might be two
inside baseball and if we don't want to
talk about it that's fine but let's
let's talk about Flipkart for a second
cell I think you'll do fine on Flipkart
it if a few things are probably true but
very bullish what did you have to
believe to be true for that to make
sense so first one is do you believe in
India in the environments 1.2 billion
people with a growing middle income with
a lack of infrastructure they've adopted
mobile they're moving to digital forms
of currency there's a lot of change
happening there a lot of challenges a
lot of governance issues it's a very
diverse place it's not really one
country it's enormous we've been there
for more than 10 years I've been there
quite a few times but deeply in India
check second question what type of
business in India and the e-commerce
business in India is under 3% of the
total business and we're certain it's
going to get bigger so you got a big pie
and it's getting bigger and you've got a
small section called e-commerce today is
that gonna get bigger
yes who are the players within that
there aren't very many the numbers been
whittling down which is you know what
we're learning about digital businesses
and e-commerce businesses it's it turns
out to aggregate business more than
busted up in some cases and there are a
few e-commerce players Flipkart was one
of them and then you get to what is flip
card well flip card is actually not just
an e-commerce business it's an ecosystem
of businesses there's a last mile
delivery component
there's an e-commerce component related
to apparel there's kind of a traditional
e-commerce business there's a payment
system called phone pay they're doing
all kinds of interesting things with AI
they're even designing apparel with AI
so it's an interesting set of positions
in the country not just a pure
e-commerce business selling dry grocery
items at a loss and then you get to the
leadership team how do you feel about
values how do you feel about their
capability we were really impressed with
their ability to solve problems and we
recognize that this is not a situation
where the business models figured out
and they're just going to execute it
it's a situation where they have a
business model and they're iterating
every hour of every day to change it
navigate the market which is exactly
what you need in India because it's it
gets disrupted in so many different ways
they have to be quick you have to be
agile you got to be on the ground you
got to know the business you got to be
able to solve problems together as a
team and they have that characteristic
and it was that set of things that
caused us to say we should do this there
just aren't very many opportunities in
the world that are that big and for a
company like Walmart that needs to move
the needle in a big way you have to take
some big bets but if you're gonna take
that much risk the rewards got to match
up and in the case of lip cart it does
and you have the ability to iterate
after that large event which is kind of
mitigate some of some of but not all of
the risk as well and we're gonna learn
things in India that we can use in other
places including here so if we talk
about experimentation and openness to
change I think for a lot of say
entrepreneurs who are listening to this
who have a 10-person company they can't
even imagine what it might be like to
experiment within say Walmart they might
think that it's trying to steer a
continent I would love to because I'm
personally curious talk about Sam's Club
I grew up going to Sam's Cup getting in
the car and it was like a pilgrimage to
go to Sam's Club to buy all the things
that we needed growing up and I recently
came across what The Wall Street Journal
had called treasure hunt items and this
may go nowhere folks I'm warning you in
advance I know I don't know but could
you please explain what this means and
you really don't know it I real
don't know what it means I mean I have a
bit like a one-line idea of what it
might mean well we must not be doing a
very good job keep in mind I was going
during like the the please tea and
arrows is early so I may have not come
across treasure on it when you go to a
Sam's Club you should experience great
quality fresh food and then other items
that you didn't expect to see that our
portable luxuries that make it feel like
there's a bit of a treasure hunt like
what's around the corner
like when you sell a swing set it should
be a special and big swing set when you
sell a cooler there should be something
about it that's different than Walmart
or some other place and a long time ago
when I was at Sam's the most extreme
example I could remember as we sold a
jet during our holiday period we hadn't
yet not we had a holiday catalog and we
made a commitment for Jeff and sold it
didn't didn't make a lot of money but it
generated a lot of buzz but we've sold
like a like a like a wine basement we've
sold extraordinary travel experiences
$70,000 price points we sold a cool
Harley one time that was 75 thousand
dollars we bought one and we told
everybody in our ad we have one so
whoever gets there first gets it and we
sold it to some plumber in Indiana if I
remember correctly okay I can't just
move on from this silt
is this like the 200 dollar hamburger
with gold leaf on it that you see in
almost every major city like once a year
for driving foot traffic in PR how much
how much of say a jet or the Harley is
driving foot traffic versus PR versus
other consideration and those were more
PR and Buzz related but we didn't
overcharge for it wasn't a Turner dollar
hamburger it was a good price on the gym
right but you do blend like with our
with our merchandising assortment
whether it's online or in stores Walmart
or Sam's or other brands you blend
together the practical with the more
aspirational all the time trying to
attract people to come to your place you
have a reputation for being very poised
very calm very even-keeled I had read
that that your competitiveness comes
from your mom which may or may not be
true again Internet question mark that's
very true so where does the poised call
me I have all the dirt all the skeletons
so the poised and calm is that nature is
that nurture and you know I'm faking
that faking it this this is something I
think a lot of people would like to fake
if that's if that's actually true oh so
tell me I mean did we talk about where
that comes from if it comes from
anywhere or if that's just kind of war
long word I'd like most of us it
probably comes from your parents and
your upbringing mostly my dad's like
that and then there the older I get the
more I see my father and me which you
know I've mixed feelings about my mom is
super competitive she is literally the
most competitive person I've ever met so
she's she's like we took a summer
vacation this year where we brought
everybody together we had 18 people
staying in this one house and a bunch of
them are 20 year old young men our sons
and my nephew's and we play beach
volleyball two-a-days for a week so
we'll be out there before it gets too
hot we'll be out there after it gets
cooler and those boys are spiking the
ball off her forehead and she just keeps
coming
it's for real the her nicknamed her
grandson's nickname for her is killer
how does that matter how does that
manifest in your life oh I'm super
competitive look I don't like to lose it
anything okay it's bad actually
sometimes because you know I play
basketball on Sunday afternoons with a
bunch of friends and my son and it's a
long-standing tradition we have on
Sunday afternoon and I hate losing so
bad that sometimes I'm not as friendly
as I should be I should be like the wise
guy at this point that's nurturing these
young men and I'm out there battling
them I would like to be a bigger person
but it's not I'm not there yet
uh hi he was reading it might've been on
the podcast exchange with Peter Thiel
and he he was describing how I might be
getting this slightly off but I'm
paraphrasing here looking for areas
where he could be less competitive
increase well-being are there areas
where you've consciously tried to
Ratchet back all the competitiveness
more no can't think of moving on
what what is the first say and this may
vary I'm sure it does vary day-to-day
but if you have the time to follow a
particular routine in the morning are
there any particular rituals or routines
that you have in the first hour or two
of way yeah very much so
it gets disrupted by travel and we
travel a lot but if I'm in town you know
shave shower get some food I'm reading
the same thing I'm reading The Wall
Street Journal well first there's a
daily devotional I'm right now Tony
dungeons got this daily devotional book
so it's I start with that doesn't take a
lot of time but I do it every day and
that's something you read that something
you know about not out loud but like I'm
in the kitchen I've got CNBC it's got
books on o muta for a second I'll read
the daily devotional then I'm into the
Wall Street Journal glancing at the New
York Times CNBC app CNBC's playing in
the background seeing me sees in the car
watching squawk box and then I get to
the office what time do you wake up
generally if you're 5:30 and in my
office about 6:30 what does your default
breakfast look like what do you eat for
breakfast
two fried eggs and toast that's the
first time I've ever been asked that I
got water Israel question two fried eggs
and toast
do you drink coffee yes how much coffee
did you see much that sounds like a
conversation ender you get to the office
alright you arrive at the office then
what do you do if you're in town is
there there I can't imagine that it's
just left to whim so there must be some
structure some lattice work on your day
or a week
are there any any must dues on a daily
or weekly basis yeah there's a lot of
variety which one things I love about it
I try to get there early enough to get a
little bit of quiet time going we've
already seen sales so when we get up in
the morning the first thing that we all
do is look at our device and you can see
in seconds how were sales around the
world yesterday by format by country so
we already know what is you know what
happened and so try to get there early
enough to get a little bit of quiet time
to get ahead on reading these days we
get a lot of reading materials like
people will send you a white paper or a
deck and say this is for tomorrow's
meeting and it's 40 pages we have a
board meeting that's got a thousand
pages of reading material so you've got
all this incoming data and it's helpful
because we're trying to get into
meetings and not you know have
old-fashioned PowerPoint flipping but
get right to the root of issues so it's
really helpful if we can people can read
things before and so there's a lot of
that going on and then there's just a
ton of variety and I talked to Lou Holtz
yesterday the former Arkansas Razorback
coach yes he coached it Notre Dame and
won a national championship but we know
him as the Arkansas Razorback coach
and Liu is responsible or working with a
health care company and he read in the
news that we were working on health care
so it's hilarious I got to ask him what
would you do could you fix Razorback
football because we won one game this
year and he said yeah by the second
quarter which I thought was hilarious
we'll come do it so you just never know
you know you can walk down the hallway
and Shaquille O'Neal will be walking
down the hallway and then you go into a
meeting on compliance in China and you
learn about you know how to manage
ethics within a within that country so
it's just a ton of variety every day and
there's really not a Down minute and
days are never what you think they're
gonna be but you try to plan so like I
learned from Mike Duke my predecessor
when I moved into our international job
that I couldn't manage my international
travel without a really good plan so
when I moved into the job one of the
things Mike did for me was to hand me
his schedule by week for the last three
years and Mike's an engineer and he's
very disciplined so he was like
Argentina I'm gonna get to once a year
China we're gonna get to three times a
year we're gonna schedule it out this
way we're in 27 countries now so I just
copied his method and like right now
in fact for about a month now I would be
able to tell you for next year where I
will be by day some of the days are kind
of planned out with board meetings and
we have this thing we call meeting week
where we bring it right together you
know mark Lori lives in New Jersey and
we just had people distributed so we
come together for one week kind of three
or four days every month where we all
get on the same page and then we
disperse out again so all those kinds of
things drive the calendar and the
discipline and we pretty much stick with
it but within a day it can get crazy
because things come up looking at your
travel schedule which I haven't seen all
of but you're describing just last few
weeks to me before we got up on stage
what are some of the self-care
techniques that were strategies that
you've developed so that you just don't
wear yourself out and what are what are
some of the what are the some of the
things you do or don't do when you're
traveling before you travel when you
land anything like that that helps you
to sustain yeah what seems to me to be a
ultra endurance marathon that doesn't
end yeah so sleeps real important for me
personally sleeps real important I wish
I needed less but I need I need seven or
eight hours time with families really
important so protecting weekends as much
as I can I work every day some but try
to manage that in a way that's not too
disruptive with my family my family's a
huge priority showing I have two boys
they're in their 20s now but man that
was really important to me so I
protected that a lot so like getting
this basketball game in on Sunday
afternoons a big deal if I can get a
good good sleep on Saturday Sunday
getting some basketball good enough
sleep while I'm traveling I'm and I'm in
pretty good shape the other thing that
happens sometimes is Paula my assistant
not call them fire breaks every once in
a while I just have to because it's too
much you just have to go back and say I
know what I was supposed to do on
Tuesday but clear it because I just need
some time to get back up on my feet read
a few things so we we will call an
audible and put a firebreak in every
once in a while so these if you think
back to any one of those fire breaks
could you give us an example of what you
then do in that day yeah it's usually
thinking it's strategy we have a
collaborative environment and it's
definitely collaborative as it relates
to strategy and I'm a blend of an
introvert and extrovert there are times
when I gotta have interaction with
people and I get energy that way and
there are times when I need to have some
quiet time and just shut the door in the
office to rethink that kind of stuff
like when we is it Burkman you take it's
one of the tests where you can kind of
assess yourself and well it could be I
can be on one of these extremes I'm kind
of right in the middle and pivot both
both ways so there are times when I just
I need happen and I can't do it in 30
minutes I need like a few hours to think
when you sit down to think for instance
I need to journal when I think otherwise
it's just like trying to grasp it
mosquitoes I can't seem to catch
anything what is what does it look like
for Doug to sit down and think do you
stare off into space do you read it if
you take its long shower and those in
the classical music what does it look
like it's drawing pictures drawing
pictures
yes schematics of how strategy works or
how a problem is Nikken
instructed so and there are people that
work with me in the room I can't hardly
have a conversation with Brett without
the whiteboard and I'm so thankful see
Jim and Lynn there
Sam Walton had a pegboard in his office
and I'm thankful for that because I had
to put up a whiteboard and people said
you can't do that at Sam Waltons office
and I'm not nope look their pictures
here he had a pegboard
a whiteboard is not that different than
a pegboard because I live kind of in a
library or a museum in Sam's office its
hallowed ground so you don't mess with
it too much right but I we got this big
whiteboard and we have conversations
where Brett's got a marker and I've got
a marker and we're drawing pictures of
boy food the customer experience went
this way or went that way or the
financials look like this instead of
that
and what does healthcare really look
like you've got a a life here you've got
care here you've got insurance what's
how does that work like how could you
help somebody be healthier and make a
margin at the same time and how could
clinics play a role in that so if for me
I'm a visual learner and when I can't
solve a problem I'm constantly trying to
draw a picture of it and trying to get
other people to draw a picture of it and
when you do those those fire breaks and
you let's just say you have blocked out
three to four hours to think how often
is that by yourself versus with other
people it's by myself I need that time
by myself but I run into things that I
don't know and so I'll run out and
interrupt place a phone call and say I'm
working on this problem what do you
think and then I'm trying to put the
phone back down or walk back to my
office and work on the next turn of the
crank on the problem thank you glad I
asked that this is a tough question but
I want to go fishing and see what we get
here so it's in the last handful of
years could be five three doesn't really
matter what new you talk about belief
earlier or new belief behavior or habit
has most improved your life or greatly
improved your life would you say any
change of thinking new thing that you do
or have stopped doing anything at all
new idea
it's the influence of other people and
it's an openness to change and I
described my morning routine for you I
would say years ago my whole life was
more routine and now the pivot is to let
go more and be more open to change and
more open to risk realizing that
continuing to do what I've always done
won't result in me being the person that
the company needs me to be and if I'm
rigid and routined and discipline too
often so will everybody else and so
anybody we were talking about risk today
with our officers and trying to
encourage them to take risk well they
won't take risk if they don't see us
taken risk and so some of the things
we've done lately I'm a really
conservative person I would not have
wanted to take those risks or
historically expected to but it's kind
of liberating and once you survive one
the next one's a little more comfortable
and if we can get everybody thinking
that way we got a shot what led to sort
of the 15-minute increment routine Doug
to the being more open to change was
there a particular event or conversation
or period of time that led you to
realize how valuable that could be what
led to the change probably more the one
thing the realization that without it we
were we are going to have a problem like
the retailer's that fail by decade that
feeling that if we don't really open
ourselves up to change here which starts
with us you know change is really cool
when it's for somebody else but when
it's for yourself it's really hard one
one experience we had in Walmart one
time this this lady that works for
Walmart was teaching us about change
management and she had us take our watch
off and put it on the other hand and
just leave it that way for a day and it
bugs the heck out
it's such a little thing but it it's an
indicative of how hard it is for us to
change personally so I like I'll put
this on my right wrist but by tonight
that'll be back on my left wrist cuz I
won't be able to take it anymore so if
you recognize that in yourself you got a
shot at doing something about it that
watch experiment this really cool friend
of mine had a similar experience where
someone he had hired to assist this
company recommended same risk but put on
the other side let's see how long it
takes you to actually turn your wrist to
that new side takes a long time as an
indication of also not the just the
potential importance of change but how
you have to give it some time for to
become instilled when you feel maybe you
don't feel this but when you feel it
seems like the the fire breaks or one
example of contending with this
overwhelmed or are unsure of what to do
besides the fire breaks is there
anything else that you do prayer prayer
do you have particular prayer or type of
prayer what does that look like it's
just really getting personal like 255
left to 255 this is definitely if you
want to dance around the ring until the
time goes out you can do that that's
there's a bigger thing at play here and
it's bigger than any of us and realizing
that and realizing that if you grip that
steering wheel too hard you will fail is
the is the moment where that fire break
comes or you let go and say okay I'm
listening
so that prayer is frequently not me
speaking it's me listening it's been
quiet and he'll put people in my life it
feels like this happens frequently where
there's no other it's no other reason I
can think of that that person said that
to me gave me that idea at that moment
other than some other higher calling
that I think is you know very real
intangible for me personally given my
faith but also helpful to the company
you know my prayer is
that the company will bless god I can't
believe you got me to say all that let's
wrap this dude up who invited this guy
1:22 I think we have time for maybe one
more but I'll see if I can sneak in - do
you have a favorite failure of yours
meaning something that seemed like a
failure at the time that ended up
setting the stage for something better
yeah a bunch of them the one that that
was so memorable for me was early that's
why I've left such a mark but if I tell
the story briefly I was the chip buyer
had a bunch of categories that I was
responsible for in food and frito-lay
chips was one of my items and I got
really excited this is early 90s because
frito-lay brought out lime-flavored
Tostitos lime and chili flavored
Tostitos and so I wanted to put it on
the front page of the Walmart tab and we
did back then print tabs mailed to
American homes you know tens of millions
of them was a big deal and everybody
knew that if the merchant screwed up the
tab you were dead like you had no career
nobody makes a tab mistake
every item every picture every price all
the in stocks got to be there because we
print on our many of these things it's
got to be great
well we we put I got the whole cover of
the tab I talked marketing into letting
me have the whole thing and we fanned
out lays and Cheetos and right there in
the front lime and chili flavored
Tostitos and the tab hit and the phone
started ringing and we learned that
frito-lay didn't have that item west of
the Mississippi yeah that was the
feeling so I'm in my 20s Shelley and I
have a young child and I'm thinking this
is it this is this is how this ends
really really bad and to make a long
story short like it was so bad I went I
went to my supervisor once I figured out
it was happening and I said here's
what's happened and he looked at me and
said you need to go tell bill fields and
bill was the chief merchant and if bill
were here I would say the same thing so
I'm not talking out of school he's like
Darth Vader in my mind like in that I'm
Darth Vader I love him but he's scary
and so I said okay let's go tell him and
my supervisor said I go on so that's
true
I've left their name out because that's
true so I go to tell bill fields that
that we've made this mistake and that
didn't go well and so the the solution
was put back on me like what are you
gonna do about it and frito-lay gave us
a coupon for a free bag of chips for any
customer that complained west of the
Mississippi and we printed them at p.m.
DC down the street and mailed them out
in 24 hours so the store managers had
something to give to the customer when
they complained but that didn't that
didn't totally satisfy the customer so
it's really bad so nobody would talk to
me like I was I don't know would he call
her pariah right
so everybody knows how bad that is so
I'm walking down the hallways and people
that I thought were my friends to have
their head down like I'm deaf like I'm
dead it's over and this lasts for like
two three days because the the tab is a
week long so you don't get to just get
up the next day and forget about it you
got to live with it for a week and there
was one person in the whole company that
reached out to me and his name's junior
Campbell Junior was a DMM a divisional
merchandise manager supervising buyers
in another area unrelated to mine and he
called me over to his desk we had an
open office environment at that time and
and in front of other people were round
he gave me a pep talk and said you
should screw it up but I believed in you
never do this again
learn from it get your head up and get
back to work and that's all I needed and
it all worked out
but I learned empathy from that mistake
I learned what it's like when somebody
that you think is really good makes a
bad mistake just a little word of
encouragement huge I know we're at zero
zero zero very last question very last
question you have a billboard that
billboard metaphorically speaking gets a
message out to billions and billions of
people anything you would put on that a
word a quote a question anything that
comes to mind that you would you would
put on that bill shop at Walmart
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday and that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's four hour workweek com
all spelled out and just drop in with
your email and you'll get the very next
one and if you sign up I hope you
enjoyed this episode of the Tim Ferriss
shows brought to you by LinkedIn the
right hire can make a huge impact on
your business the wrong hire can crater
your business and I have seen an example
after example from thousands of my
readers at a minimum where they have
told these stories of how finding the
right person at the right time and in
some cases not even asking what should I
do
but asking who should I find because
that person can help me determine what
exactly to do more intelligently I've
had a chance to hire two such people in
the last year that has just made my
business take a quantum leap forward and
my complexity in my personal and
business life get cut dramatically I
mean this type of simplification cannot
be overvalued
you think a lot about hiring and I think
a lot about hiring and it is a skill
that I've had to learn it is important
to find the right person but where do
you find that person you can post a job
on a job board and hope that that right
person finds your job that they are on
the Internet happening to scan something
here and there and then find you but
think about it how often do you hang out
on job boards the answer is probably not
very often so don't leave finding
someone great to chance when you can
post your job exactly where people go
every day to make connections grow in
their careers and discover job
opportunities that is linked in most
LinkedIn members haven't recently
visited the top job board but 9 out of
10 members are open to new opportunities
and with 70% of the US workforce on
LinkedIn hosting there is the best way
to get your job opportunity in front of
more of the right people and you can be
very very highly targeted and specific
people who are qualified for the role
you have and ready for something new
this is where you find them it's the
best way find that person that key
person will help you grow your business
this is why a new hire is made every 10
seconds using LinkedIn that's bonkers
every 10 seconds it's a head to
linkedin.com /tm and get $50 off your
first job post that's linkedin.com
forward slash tim TI m to get $50 off
your first jobless LinkedIn comm forward
slash Tim take a look terms and
conditions
you
you